leanne is already struggling to pay the
bills does it feel like that's in charge
sometimes yeah yeah that takes
everything every bit of money
everything it may as well eat all my
food as well because it is eating my
money for food
her partner works but even with no
tumble dryer no dishwasher and rationing
use energy at her home near
stratford-upon-avon costs more than the
rent and a further increase is
terrifying
scared
worried for my kids how we're going to
manage everything we've already been
going without because of how much it's
costing
we've been to four food banks
in the last couple of months which is
horrible to admit
for millions of families life is about
to get harder with gas and electricity
prices due to rise 80 percent from
october the first an increase the
regulator says is unavoidable
we are clear that with the change we're
seeing today and indeed the change we
might see over winter we need urgent and
decisive action from that new
ministerial team and we stand ready to
work with them a lot of work is being
done people really do need to understand
that because all of us need to get ahead
of this and i'm confident that if we
work together we will get through this
for customers this winter
wholesale gas prices are driving the
increase as russia restricts supply yet
despite bills now almost three times
higher than a year ago the current prime
minister and the candidates to replace
him offered no new plan to help
the pipeline of cash coming through over
the next few months and
through the
the autumn and the the winter but that
is clearly now going to be
augmented increased by extra cash that
the government is plainly going to be
announcing in september
the price rise is so huge that even in
outwardly affluent towns like stratford
middle income in the middle of england
energy anxiety will become a mainstream
economic experience
even with existing government support
this rise will push a third of
households into fuel poverty and more
will follow next year with prices
forecast to rise again that means that
even in places like this thousands of
families without more help will face
genuine hardship and for all but the
most well-off it will be normal to
wonder how you're going to pay the bills
personal trainer rebecca and teacher and
artist andrew live comfortably in the
city they know they're fortunate but
they're not immune cutting spending and
putting holiday plans on hold
we don't know what the next few months
are going to look like
and we haven't really been in that
situation before when we've had to think
well actually we can't plan ahead too
much because we don't know
you know how this is going to really
impact us
without further massive state support
the coming months could be catastrophic
for those least able to afford it
but this is a universal crisis that will
touch every business and home
paul kell says sky news in
stratford-upon-avon